you uh you said that
you were always an old soul and see the
world as if you're 200 years old i like
this thing
because your creative vision allows you
to see the final piece you've created or
you're creating very quickly quicker
than others
um
i i heard that as if you've almost like
lived many lives you have this
experience that allows you to see the
vision so let me ask you on creativity
where does this creativity behind reza
come from
this both musically and film-wise
that i don't i don't know if i have the
answer to that one right but is it no
seriously where does it come from
the only thing i could say about that is
that for some
reason if it seems endless
and that's
peculiar
when i think about it myself
because i was taught
a lot of
things from the gizza you know
he introduced me to mathematics
he introduced me to hip-hop himself
the break dancing
you know i got other cousins that
introduced me to graffiti
uh the cousins they introduced me to
dj and like i realized that i had a lot
of introductions but the judges are
definitely
you know
my older cousin gave me a lot of
early inspirations
and
not saying that
he's not creative as creative as he was
daniel now
i just didn't
like the wide span of creativity
i don't see him doing that right
and
i don't see
my cut you know the cousins that taught
me how to dj i didn't see them
move from dj into making the beats
you know
my cousin that uh
you know who actually got me into
instruments
i didn't see him
leave funk and rock he didn't call like
i'm an orchestra composer now yeah
so
so
i just said to myself i just accept
myself
as a artist as a creative artist that's
what i am i i
that i have to accept that now where it
comes from
i don't know if i was just trying to try
to say where it comes from like hey give
it give me give me some type of answer
i'll say from life itself
but what does it feel like because you
mentioned during this pandemic for
example for some reason more came to you
in terms of writing
and so do you feel like you're just
receiving signals from elsewhere or
like do you do you feel like it's hard
work or you're just waiting
wow it's not even waiting or no is it
hard work it's almost like i said in one
of my other lyrics this is for the mc
part of it i said emceeing to me as easy
as breathing
so it's like breathing yeah it's just
like
in fact there's actually a scientific
scientific thing i read about that now
you might be nanny said that you heard
this i know you've had to hear this
they say that
you know the atoms in our atmosphere
which seem to be infinite in number
are not infinite in the space they
occupy
how can they end our atmosphere
and so there's a chance
that at least one million atoms that you
breathed in your life
was breathed by galileo
you heard this before all right yeah
okay
it's very accurate okay
how does your body digest it
well let's start at the fact that most
of the atoms
in our
what that we're made of is from like
stars right from stars burst so like
we're all really connected fundamentally
somehow and then they get the atoms that
make up our body come and leave and the
same with the cells that are in our body
they die and are reborn and we don't pay
attention to any of that that all just
goes through us
i don't know
that
that makes me feel
like um
i'm not an individual i'm just
a finger of something much bigger some
much bigger organism well because you're
drinking the coffee there yeah
right you're going to digest that
you're going to digest those atoms
whether you're going to put them through
the bowel or through the urination it's
coming out or maybe you'll sweat it out
yeah you might sneeze it out yeah but
they're going to make their way out how
do you digest the atoms if you just
breathe in galileo
right how do that's what i think a
artist does
i think something in the artist it's
like some people eat things and they're
going to gain weight some people ain't
going to gain but they want to gain
muscle
my i'm just giving an analogy here i'm
thinking that the artist breathes in
and
translates it into the art first they
got to hear it i think most of us don't
hear that like don't
we receive it but it just right it's not
yeah we not have the frequency i said
this to about artists
and even you know new yorker consider
ourselves artists in a certain way but
not you know
but let's just say
there's only
one million artists in the world yeah
good
just you know it's probably with it
if you divide that into the population
what would that what part of the table
would it be a tiny part yeah it might be
that right
yeah
um and yeah it's that
that inspires that
oh yeah you know what's so crazy about
that though
there's also a chance i'm just going
numbers and i'm just hypothesizing with
you but there's also a chance that all
of this
is actually informing that yeah
the artist is just watching this all of
this
all the the chaos of this yeah so it's
it's hard to know where the beauty comes
from is it the artist or the chaos from
the so i just so i said i don't know i
don't have the answer but i if i was to
be forced to say or something answer and
you're not twisting my arm but yeah i'll
say i can if you want me no thank you
i'll say life
yeah yeah life
you